[Music]  earlier this week Apple announced it  would use robots to help build the new  iPhone 6 that's a big story they're  gonna use robots to build the iPhone 6  well I say big deal cuz we've been using  robots to make this show since the  beginning in fact half of my office  staff consists of robots check it out  hundreds of them doing the small but  vital jobs you can find in any office  the robot that's always on Facebook the  robot who hangs out in the break room  and spouts tired catchphrases working  hard or hardly working the robot who's  on a loud personal call holiday events a  injections or suppositories the robot  who steals you're clearly labeled yogurt  from the fridge the robot who makes  passive-aggressive comments when you  leave a little early I guess it's a half  day the robot who looks at porn in the  office and turns it off when a human  gets too close they're still working out  the kinks on that way  [Applause]  you